et salut à tous les amis aujourd'hui je
vous fais un petit tuto parce que vous
avez été nombreux à me demander où est
ce que je trouvais mes musiques pour mes
vidéos bah je vous explique tout ça
juste après cette intro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà c'est un sujet qui me tient
à coeur
effectivement la musique sur les vidéos
moi je mets un petit point d'honneur à
essayer d'avoir des musiques de qualité
oh bien sûr tout est relatif c'est une
question de goût et ça fait plusieurs
fois dans les commentaires que ça
revient ou est-ce que tu trouve ta
musique qu'est ce que c'est c'est donc
je vous dis ça tout de suite mais juste
avant je vais vous précisez bien
évidemment que cette vidéo n'est pas
sponsorisé et que je ne suis pas payé
pour vous dire ce que je vais vous dire
après alors il ya plusieurs solutions il
ya du gratuit et du payant mais il faut
savoir que sur youtube si vous utilisez
un mp3 que vous avez téléchargés
légalement ou illégalement mais qui
contient des droits d'auteur et bien
votre vidéo pourra soit bon juste dans
le meilleur des cas ne pas pouvoir être
monétisée ça la limite ce pas bien grave
mais elle pourra être supprimé et c'est
même possible que vous puissiez vous
prendre un strike c'est à dire ben un
avertissement au bout de trois strike
sur youtube la chaîne est fermé donc
faut faire assez attention avec avec la
vidéo et puis c'est une question aussi
de respect des droits d'auteurs et des
artistes qui ont créé ces musiques et
c'est un sujet qui me tient vraiment à
coeur pour avoir fait de la musique et
en faire encore voilà c'est assez
important de penser à ces artistes qui
créent cette musique et puis qui
permettent d'avoir des vidéos de qualité
parce qu'il ya ce fond sonore qui fait
quand même là on aurait alors première
solution c'est tout simple essai gratuit
dans l'espace youtube creator quand vous
avez une chaîne youtube dans l'onglet
créé il ya un espace qui s'appelle
bibliothèque audio et dans cette
bibliothèque vous allez pouvoir prouver
tout un tas de musique assez sympa que
vous pourrez intégrer gratuitement sur
vos vidéos alors il y en a certaines il
faudra cité la paternité donc l'auteur
dans la description par exemple ou dans
la vidéo directement voilà qu'il faudra
dire à vos spectateurs qui a composé
cette musique et d'autres morceaux où il
n'y a pas besoin vous mettez juste autre
musique et puis vous êtes tranquille il
ya un moteur de recherche qui est
vraiment sympa qui permet de faire des
recherches par genre musical par humeur
en fonction de la sensibilité que vous
voulez donner à votre vidéo si vous
voulez que ce soit quelque chose de
rythmé de joyeux où quelque chose de
dramatique voilà vous allez pouvoir
trouver votre bonheur dans cette
bibliothèque là à noter aussi qu'il y a
des petits effets sonores vous allez
pouvoir télécharger pour ajouter pas
différent effet à vos vidéos voilà ça
c'est la première solution
la deuxième solution c'est celle que
j'utilise moi qui est payante un site
qui s'appelle épidémique semble et que
j'ai découvert va grâce à peter mc
kinnon dont je vous parlais dans la
vidéo dit chen à regarder absolument
donc allé la voir je la mets dans la
description et c'est un site qui propose
des musiques spécialement étudié pour
les créateurs youtube donc on souscrit
un abonnement qui coûte 10 euros par
mois et vous avez accès à tout un
catalogue
dick de vraiment très très très bonne
qualité moi j'aime beaucoup
il ya aussi voilà pareil que sur la
bibliothèque youtube il ya des effets
sonores il y avait des choses qui sont
vraiment sympas petit plus des films x
on sait qu'on peut télécharger les
différentes pistes les différents
éléments d'un morceau indépendamment
c'est à dire que si vous voulez mettre
uniquement le basse batterie de la
musique qui vous plaît parce que je ne
sais pas ça correspond plus à votre
vidéo vous pouvez complètement le faire
alors vous mettez ça dans garageband
dans audacity pu vous refaites votre mix
sans les éléments qui vous gêne si vous
voulez juste enlever la voix c'est
possible aussi pour avoir juste de
l'instrumental et la qualité audio est
vraiment très très très très bonne comme
avec la bibliothèque youtube on pourra
chercher par humeur par genre par
instrument par longueur on pourra
chercher aussi par tempo s'ils ont
quelque chose de rapide si on veut
quelque chose de l'an donc c'est
vraiment très complet et c'est vraiment
très facile de trouver la musique qui va
correspondre à l'humeur de la vidéo que
vous voulez tournée qui va donner
vraiment ce petit plus parce que
forcément si je mets une musique comme
ça sur une vidéo je vais avoir très
sérieux très voilà très dans l'émotion
c'est quoi alors si je mets une vidéo
comme ça ça va avoir l'air pêchue savall
et revoilà ça pète c'est cool c'est au
mas la pêche sont à la patate c'est
vraiment bien donc vraiment très
important la bande-son ça peut changer
complètement votre vidéo le style de
votre vidéo et l'effet que ça va donner
le cas à produire sur les gens alors
vous allez me demander pourquoi j'ai
choisi épidémique sound parce que c'est
quand même 10 euros par mois que ça fait
un petit budget quand même alors il ya
deux raisons 1 je trouve vraiment les
morceaux de qualité
j'aime je les écoute enfin sans
forcément mettre dans la vidéo j'écoute
certains morceaux qui me plaisent comme
ça juste par plaisir et la deuxième
raison c'est que je trouve vraiment bien
de rémunérer les artistes à mon petit
niveau
voilà moi en fait en revenus
publicitaires j'ai environ 10 euros par
mois mais ça fait une opération blanche
au final voilà l'argent que je gagne
entre guillemets sur youtube je le
réinvestis pour rémunérer des artistes
qui font de la musique de qualité qui
font voilà des productions qui sont
vraiment sympas ce qui me permet de vous
faire des vidéos de qualité aussi je
l'espère d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires n'hésitez pas à me dire si
les musiques que je place dans les
vidéos vous plaisent si voilà si vous
avez d'autres plans je sais qu'à plein
de sites de musique libre aussi qui
existe comme jeanine d'eau par exemple
qui permet de télécharger des musiques
libres de droit aussi qu'ils sont
vraiment sympas un petit peu trop touffu
à mon goût c'est un peu plus difficile
de s'y retrouver parce qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses mais voilà maintenant
vous avez plusieurs pistes si vous
voulez rajouter des musiques sympa à vos
vidéos et voilà les amis c'est terminé
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura été utile merci en tout
cas de l'avoir regardé si elle vous a
plu si elle vous a servi
mettez un petit pouce vers le haut ça
fait toujours plaisir si vous êtes
nouveau sur cette chaîne n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner si vous ne voulez rien
rater de ce qui va suivre
et moi je vous dis à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo